one key is a travel Awards program
designed for anyone who goes anywhere
wow wow that's a large group use and
earn one key rewards on Expedia
hotels.com and verbo so you can earn one
key cash on a cruise and use it on an
eligible vacation home yeah you'll start
saving as soon as you join take a flight
pick a rental car stay three nights in a
hotel and get to Silver tier in a single
trip at silver gold and platinum members
get extra perks like room upgrades where
available and free breakfast oh man
that's my favorite breakfast unlock
rewards on your next trip with one key
rewards on any way you travel we have an
ongoing saga on this podcast that
continues to write its own narrative
terrible
I'm not writing and I'm just living it
remember that uh Jay Elmore who runs a
deli in New York has taken our sandwich
creations and has been selling them and
he has an update on the numbers he's
right he's running actual science now
okay because last time you also you
complained about the fact that I had an
American flag in mind and you said that
that was responsible for why I was
leading sales I think that goosed things
a little bit okay so because uh you know
we're ever we're patriotic people and
yours had an American flag and ours had
no flag so I think that put us at a
disadvantage he took the flag out thank
you and started the tally again good
okay these are these are Jay's words
once again I just wanted to say you made
my day with the mention of the on the
podcast I'm so happy you guys are
enjoying it you're welcome
thank you Wilford Brimley yeah you
sounded angry well it's a lot of skin
off your nose no Free Pub 551 sandwiches
sold final tally so far sona's Euro 172
Conan's corned beef 186
Maddie melt 193. oh these are all pretty
close yes and then it goes on okay
um
he said I will cross the 200 Mark today
Conan may cross it too
he said Maddie Mel these are updates as
they come in Maddie melt just hit 200
Conan is at six away I said stall it
take it off the menu meaning yours where
is this uh New York I know but let's be
a little clear about where this place is
because I'd like to make a personal
appeal I don't know where it is exactly
isn't this EJ's luncheonette yeah I
believe it's on the Upper East Side
Third Avenue between 73rd and 74th EJ's
a a very nice guy named Jay came out of
his uh his Diner and said hello to me we
chatted for a little bit that's when the
idea for maybe these sandwiches came up
uh and I would just like to say that my
sandwich
is I believe it's a corned beef Russian
dressing yeah coleslaw it's a terrific
sandwich it's a it's a classic and it's
called the Conan O'Brien or just the
Conan I think it's just I'm not sure
okay
so you're saying that the name
recognition is important well what I'm
saying is I would like to win this oh
and so I'm talking to all my listeners
now who might be oh no yeah who might be
in New York City just hear me out oh uh
maybe give my sandwich a try no go there
and order it and then if you see me
around New York City I'm there a lot
just mention I had your sandwich Conan
and maybe you get a little quick hug and
a selfie that's all oh my God I can't
use the bully pulpit like that yeah you
have to give equal time to us I don't
know what kind of cash I'll have on me
but uh I don't carry a lot of cash I'll
just say that right you're gonna go and
just buy a ton of sandwiches probably no
no I'm gonna probably will I'm gonna
have David hopping yeah go buy a lot of
sandwiches today you have to watch out
for the Sona you can make your plea for
your year mine is clearly the healthiest
oh thank you for saying that oh nothing
gets people into a diner like a healthy
choice good job yes if you are going to
EJ's luncheonette because you're really
feeling like
slimming down
rush over and get sona's Giro gyro gyro
I love to pretend not to know how to say
and then yours is what a foreign
sandwich right what no mine's the most
patriotic thing it's called a Maddy melt
yeah what's it what's a patty melt yeah
with
um on Hawaiian bread yeah that's
calories death that's what do you mean
cholesterol fat no no that's not the way
to go after it
into the 10 th this is America you
forgot where you were yeah New York
paper York they walk they're healthy
they work out Hawaii became a state very
late
I'm the star on the flag that's the
bread you want
based in New York with Hawaiian bread
I'm covering not only the continental
United States but practically Hawaii and
Alaska with corned beef I am covering I
mean just all cultures no you know yes
what yes uh the the Jewish people the
Irish people done that's it seriously
I'm sorry the Greeks are responsible for
our whole civilization okay
first of all what did you say the Greeks
did they they're like responsible for
like modern type of civilization yeah
what have they done lately right uh
exceptions of money yeah I know a bunch
of tax shelters exactly the tax shelter
they attack self you know what Socrates
uh kept all of his money in a tax
shelter okay that was his big advice to
his students all right great great
shelter your money he said uh same thing
with Plato yeah yeah bird dropped a tax
shelter on his head and that's how he
died oh because the U.S is doing great
you guys what did you say yeah the US is
doing great attitudes like that yeah
okay well guess what your gyro I think
is plummeted because it's healthy and
its inventor hates America oh I would
say hey give the Conan O'Brien a try
EJ's lunch tonight
EJ's luncheonette just go on by check it
out the Conan O'Brien
corned beef coleslaw
here's my message I say listener eat
whatever you think sounds delicious be
you be you don't fall prey to sway don't
fall prey this way
eat what you want to be eat the meat
don't fall prey this way eat the meat
I'll take a selfie with you I'll give
you a quick hello I'm easy to spot in
New York if you think you see Jane Lynch
wearing a red wig that's me if you do
buy mine you don't have to take a selfie
you can get out of it all right thank
you I think we accomplished a lot there
and thanks to Jay Elmore for selling uh
creating these sandwiches in our image
and there's a very good chance that this
Saga will actually have quite a
resolution possibly even in the flesh
yes yeah I know what you're talking
about yeah more later why don't we get a
piece of these sandwiches sorry I know
we ended it but why don't we get paid
for a piece of these sandwiches like we
should get a check no no check no nobody
else no we're not doing this for money
oh what are we doing for
Real Estate
foreign